certaines rues de liège sont sous l'eau
ce soir la meuse ne cesse de monter
certains habitants prennent des risques
en tentant d'évacuer
aux abords du fleuve la population est
invitée à fuir ses rives désormais trop
dangereux plus à l'est dans la commune
de pépin ster
les pompiers se battent littéralement
contrôlant
à cette fenêtre une mère de famille
lance un sos image symbole d'une
belgique endeuillé ce soir
alors on pense bien sûr très fort au
belge actuelle vécu un mois de juillet
catastrophique c'est vrai qu'en france
aussi on a eu un autre phénomène c'est
dans le var avec les incendies regardez
c'était le 16 août ce plus de 6300
hectares de forêt voilà regardent
l'incendié n'est pas encore maîtrisée et
cet après midi il progresse toujours une
progression attisés par le vent et
surtout des températures caniculaires
sur place parce que glissant sommes des
pompiers du var mais aussi des renforts
d'autres départements ils sont surtout
appuyée par des moyens aériens nombreux
c'est un incendie d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle qui s'étend sur plus de
20 km et ce soir alors que le feu n'est
toujours pas éteint le bilan est déjà
terrible 6000 hectares parcourus dans la
réserve naturelle des morts l'une des
plus belles forêts du var une
catastrophe
alors il ya eu également l'espagne bien
entendu il ya eu l'algérie il ya une
vraie salle il ya eu la grèce et il ya
eu new york la de septembre des pluies
torrentielles et des inondations
soudaines ont frappé la ville de new
york et sa région alors ça c'est
impressionnant vraiment ce qu'on a vu au
françois c'est vraiment ça c'est le
nombre de morts aussi observé
regarde et
bord incroyables selon les mots de ce
présentateur américain qui découvre les
images en direct le métro de new york en
train de se frayer un chemin sous des
trombes d'eau des pluies diluviennes se
sont abattues sur new york cette nuit
les restes de l'ouragan ida qui a frappé
le sud des états unis il ya quatre jours
des inondations et d'impressionnantes
tornade dans le new-jersey l'état
d'urgence a été déclaré
voilà ça c'est vrai que ça nous fait
extrêmement peur hein franchement qu'est
ce qui va se passer il se passe des
choses qu'on voyait pas avant françois
qu'est ce que ça signifie toutes ces
inondations à new york ses feux en
espagne aussi ce qu'on a vu qu'il faut
s'inquiéter
clairement il faut s'inquiéter parce
qu'il va y avoir de plus en plus de
phénomènes comme celui là et qu'ils vont
devenir de plus en plus violents alors
on le sait depuis trente ans un logis et
que le dis depuis trente ans qu'il va y
avoir de plus en plus de vagues de
chaleur extrême de plus en plus de
précipitations intenses mais là on les a
chez nous et pendant longtemps on a cru
que ces impacts du changement climatique
c'est l'être ailleurs sa lettre en
afrique en asie loin
500 m dans 500 m c'est que comme le
disait déjà il ya 30 ans ben ont
maintenant des trente ans plus tard et
on les a autour de nous et il va y en
avoir de plus en plus donc ça veut dire
que c'est une sorte de réalité nouvelle
à laquelle il va falloir s'habituer mais
non mais c'est vrai que j'ai fait est ce
qu'on est prêt à
avoir affronté voilà ce genre de choses
pas du tout mais pas du tout pas du tout
c'est à dire qu'on regarde encore ses
impacts du changement climatique comme
on regardait le courant n'avait russe
quand il était encore en chine où tu as
vu la crise en se disant ça viendra
jamais ici et ça va rester en chine et
là on se rend compte que on n'est pas du
tout près on voit bien les
infrastructures à new york on voit bien
ce qui s'est passé en belgique moynier
jeu la ville c'est la ville où je suis
né donc je sais très bien ce qui s'est
passé et on va très bien qu'on n'est pas
du tout préparés parce qu'on a toujours
pensé que ça allait arriver qu aux
autres ou dans un futur cela alors on
parle plus de réchauffement climatique
maintenant on parle de changement
climatique pourquoi alors en réalité la
température se réchauffe
là on a déjà pris 1,2 degré dans la vue
par rapport aux niveaux de température
avant la révolution industrielle donc
avant le 19e siècle par rapport aux
prévisions c'est exactement se passe
exactement ce qui se passe exactement
c'est ça le problème sans sa compagne
sur le climat c'est avec ce boulot on
espère tout le temps se tromper et le
problème c'est qu'on ne se trompe jamais
et que chaque jour la réalité confirme
ce que les modèles avaient prédit donc
l'heure de déjà pris 1,2 degré les
objectifs de l'accord de paris ces deux
degrés maximum d'ici 2100 et même si
possible un degré et ce réchauffement
tomber un pur produit des impacts très
très différents à différents endroits du
globe ce qui peut être trompeur
d'ailleurs parce qu'à certains moments
on va avoir des vagues de froid et les
gens disent mais comment ça se fait
qu'on ne dit que la température sur les
choses alors que je vois bien qu'il fait
moins 10 devant chez moi ça produit les
phénomènes et très localisée c'est pour
ça que parfois on va parler aussi de
dérèglement climatique alors juste quand
on nous parle de petits gestes au
quotidien à faire ça ça change rien
parce maintenant on peut pas dire que ça
change rien à dire que ça suffit c'est
une condition nécessaire mais pas
suffisant on estime selon les pays que
les petits gestes du quotidien on sait
bien rouler à vélo manger des fruits et
légumes de saison et c'est ça représente
entre 25 et 40% des émissions d'un pays
donc ça veut dire que si tout le monde
vivait comme greta tandberg ont réduire
est à peu près 40% des émissions 15 a
fait des dégâts des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mondiales donc c'est
important mais ça ne suffit pas parce
qu'à côté de ça il y à toutes les
émissions qui sont contrôlés par les
décisions des gouvernements par les
choix industriels etc
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut non
seulement agir individuellement comme
consommateur mais qu'il faut aussi agir
ensemble collectivement comme citoyen et
françois on voit des malades et des
catastrophes arriver est ce que comme
vous faites des prévisions incroyable
est-ce que vous n'arrivez pas à
anticiper un petit peu ce qu est ce que
vous savez ce qui va arriver bientôt ou
pas du tout de mieux en mieux est ce
qu'il ya des catastrophes qui sont là et
on peut pas prédire au jour près mais
par contre on peut dire que voilà dans
telle région alors soit par exemple le
prochain volume du rapport léger qui va
être publié en février prochain elle est
des chapitres est jeune on va pouvoir
dévoila par région voilà à peu près ce
qui va se passer qu'est-ce qui va
lentement là alors très clairement pour
l'europe par exemple on va avoir de plus
en plus de vagues de chaleur si on est
dans un scénario à deux degrés on va
avoir un nom de vague de chaleur qui va
être multipliée par cinq
si on est dans un scénario plus cap
degrés donc ça c'est le scénario
catastrophe le nombre de vagues de
chaleur x 9 alors ça c'est les chiffres
qu'on peut donner maintenant on va
partir au rire les spectateurs pourquoi
serait une catastrophe ça parce que ça
veut dire que dans certains endroits du
monde
littéralement ça va devenir inhabitable
c'est à dire que les températures vont
devenir invivable on a eu des
températures cet effet devrait approcher
les 50 degrés dans plusieurs endroits du
monde si on a des températures pour
longer à plus de 50 degrés basse et des
zones non plus plus habitée est donc
vraiment l'enjeu du changement
climatique c'est la question de
l'habitabilité de la planète où est ce
qu'on va pouvoir habiter françois ce
réchauffement là que vous avez prévu
pour l'europe il a quoi sert à quoi sert
à 2 3 ans et plus loin ah non c'est donc
là on est à 2 degrés accor 1 5 degré on
vers 2035 d'accord et alors deux degrés
soit on parvient pas à réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et on
y sera vers 2050 2060 soit ont permis à
se mettre dans les clous de l'accord de
paris et on peut espérer qu'on atteigne
2 degrés que vers 2100 vous y croyez ou
pas du tout c'est pas blanc ou noir je
pense qu'il faut quelque part j'ai
souvenir d'une demi finale de foot de
ligue des champions ou liverpool était
mené 3-0 à sa maison ça s'améliore
la finale où j'étais pas dans le
vestiaire à la mi temps mais je pense
pas que l'entraîneur du joueur bon les
gars la victoire vous y croyez vous
pensez qu'on va voir la coupe non je
pense que l'entraîneur du joueur les
gars il va falloir tout donner en
seconde mi temps pour remonter le score
et ils ont remonté le score donc je
crois que quelque part se dire on y
croit on n'y croit pas on optimiste ou
pessimiste c'est un luxe de riches au
fait en fait il faut tout donner dans la
sphère g on essaiera de limiter au
maximum la casse mais j'ai sauf que là
vous prenez l'exemple d'une action
humaine qui peut tout changer à la mi
temps et ça venez nous dire les gestes
au quotidien ça certains lescariens
voici quarante les
décisions dans les prairies ce qui est
un tout petit peu les décisions des pays
elles vont pas changer y a pas un pays
qui va arrêter de se développer la chine
va pas dire on arrête de produire de la
pensée énergie parce que ils ont envie
de devenir riche la superpuissance donc
ma question allait dire les condamner
ces voix là il est très rare il est trop
tard en mai n'est pas vrai de dire il
est trop tard c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui le point positif c'est que
le climat s'est vu la première
préoccupation des français c'est à dire
que devant le chômage devant la sécurité
devant l'immigration ce qui tracasse le
plus c'est français c'est le climat ça
veut dire que quelque part les
politiques vont devoir s'en occuper et
ça veut dire qu'il ya des choses qu'on
peut faire individuellement et aussi des
choses qu'on peut faire ensemble on peut
voter on peut en parler dans le vide r
c'est pour ça que c'est important d'en
parler aujourd'hui dans tpm p il y a
aussi plein de choses qu'on peut faire
avec les investissements en une énorme
source de notre empreinte carbone c'est
les investissements que font les banques
en notre nom c'est à dire que si vous
avez des produits de départ et un peu
classique des plans d'épargne-logement
ou deux assurances vie sans le savoir eh
ben vous financer les énergies fossiles
à votre insu parce que vauban les
banques vont placer l'argent dans les
énergies fossiles et donc à côté des
petits gestes du quotidien il ya plein
de choses qu'on peut faire ensemble
collectivement oui est ce que vous
répondez aux climato-sceptiques qui
disent que tout ça c'est naturel que
c'est des cycles immuable et qu'il faut
pas trop s'inquiéter au final assez
certain il ya eu des cycles de
changement climatique
minable il y en aura encore c'est à dire
que la température a déjà été beaucoup
plus élevé par le passé elle sera encore
sans doute beaucoup plus élevé dans le
futur et le changement climatique dont
on parle c'est rien du tout c'est
peanuts à l'échelle de l'histoire de la
terre qui fait 4 milliards et demi
d'années juste 30 soit la différence
c'est que à l'époque de ces changements
climatiques on n'était pas là sur terre
et donc lors je sais pas que sauver la
planète la manuelle va évidemment
survivre à l'espèce humaine l'enjeu
c'est de la garder habitable pour tout
ça françois est ce qu'à des catastrophes
qui sont prévues la pole et les bras
pour cette année 2022 qui va arriver ou
pas du tout alors très rassemblement on
va encore avoir une saison au tour à
gand
de plus en plus importante il faut se
rappeler que les inondations à new york
c'est les restes de l'ouragan ida qui a
touché le sud des états unis est le vol
reliant il ya quelques jours et
heureusement on voit que depuis katrina
le sud des états unis c'est mieux
préparer la loi candidats qui étaient
comparables en force alors à gand
katrina il ne fait que trois ou quatre
morts à la nouvelle-orléans cu 2000
morts en 2005 d'accord mais et henry
n'aura alors pour pour l'europe on va
avoir évidemment de plus en plus de
vagues de chaleur et de précipitations
exceptionnelles qui généralement vont
alterner l'une avec l'autre à se
produire sur tout l'été on voit avoir un
phénomène d'érosion côtière est à dire
au niveau de la mer va monter de plus en
plus ça va encore des feux comme on a vu
dans le var ou des crues voilà qu'on va
en avoir en septembre certainement mais
c'est certain que les conditions sont
davantage réuni l'été pour des forêts et
pour les groupes ne pas les exclure sur
d'autres saisons non plus il est crue
qui font des dégâts incroyables 500 oui
ça c'est très clairement il y aura de
plus en plus de plus en plus d'accord ce
qu'on peut pas encore dire avec
précision septembre exactement et à quel
endroit précisément alors comment s'y
préparer à ça on ne peut rien faire a
assis il ya plein de choses c'est à dire
en termes d'aménagement du territoire
est ce qu'on va faire habiter les gens
où est ce qu'on va autoriser les
constructions il ya plein de choses à
faire en termes de végétalisation du
territoire d'arrêter la bétonisation il
ya des choses à faire en termes
d'évacuation des populations en terme d'
alerte précoce d'ailleurs que en
belgique ou en allemagne s'ils avaient
mieux anticipé à partir des alertes qui
était donné par les services météo s'ils
avaient évacué les populations on aurait
pu la lui montrera donc on aura pu
l'anticiper oui bien sûr mais tout ça
c'est clairement la conséquence d'une
planète qu'on a usé utilisez qu'on n'a
pas respecté d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu
un pendant de confinement la nature a
repris ses droits parce que la nature
paribas serait elle se refait c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'il faut pas minimiser
le fait que 40% car les normands passe à
moitié c'est énorme et si on vivait tous
comme bertone bel
exemple quand on reçoit notre fiche
d'impôts qu'il y ait une petite lettre
avec le top 30 des actions que tout le
monde devrait faire par exemple parce
que aujourd'hui les français et même
mondialement on est très intéressés par
l'environnement mais concrètement on ne
sait pas quoi faire il faudrait qu'on
soit guidée il faut donner plus
d'information je
joue ce qu'il faudrait donner le taux de
concentration gaz à effet de serre
implosera au sens soit juste on
entendait delphine là le confinement le
fait que les gens ne sortent plus trop
voie lactée plus trop de voitures est-ce
que ça fait du bien ou pas du tout on
n'a vu aucun on n'avait rien vu parce
que là où bien faire mieux en terme
d'offre mine de rien on peut pas fermer
adoption se dit c'est avec tout ce qui
s'est passé pendant on a eu un
confinement peut peut-être pendant voilà
pendant toute une en tout pendant tes
charmes avant tout est bon la mesure est
alors l'impact du contenu en 2020 que
c'est moins 7% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre au niveau mondial juste
devant 2 7% -1 7% pas mal moins 7% par
an c'est ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
respecter les objectifs de l'accord de
paris qui accordent entre le problème
évidemment mais c'est clair personne ne
veut reproduire le confinement à faire
revivre l'année 2020 donc c'est votre
compte des façons d'y arriver qu'on
choisisse et pas de façon qu'on subisse
ans